[Musique]
me voici dans ce magnifique cadre
pour témoigner de la manière dont j'ai
traversé plusieurs cadres
le premier j'ai dû fuir à 15 ans
le cadre de mon enfance
limité à trois collines d'un petit
village au cœur de
l'Anatolie en Turquie
où je vivais très heureux
et voilà soudain mes parents deviennent
très inquiets de mon frère et on le met
dans un bus
pour partir en Allemagne chez une de nos
sœurs
et moi aussi la semaine suivante je me
retrouve dans ce même bus pour partir en
Allemagne rejoindre une autre sœur qui
était à Coblence en Allemagne mais
pourquoi
parce que ma famille mon village mon
environnement direct
appartiennent à une minorité religieuse
nommée à Lévy
une communauté oppressée menacée parfois
massacrée
nous sommes le 12 septembre 1980 le coup
d'État militaire vient de se produire
et ça devient encore plus dangereux pour
tous les minorités et moi à 15 ans
quitter sa famille mon village mes amis
et mon chien
c'était une vraie déchirure
mais il y avait quand même quelque chose
qui me motivait un petit peu c'est que
j'allais pouvoir manger de la banane et
du chocolat même peut-être que j'aurai
une bicyclette en Allemagne
en Allemagne mon frère en étant plus âgé
il obtient l'asile politique malgré les
démarches
ma demande avait été rejetée parce que
j'étais mineur vous savez en Allemagne
Nine
du coup il fallait changer du cadre
cadre vie
soit j'allais retourner à l'insécurité à
l'oppression en Turquie soit sur les
tenter de aller en France retrouver une
autre de nos sœurs
et voilà à la frontière
je trouve une famille française qui
m'attendait dans une voiture
immatriculée 57
pour me récupérer et passer de l'autre
côté
je me souviendrai toujours le douanier
qui filtrer les véhicules à l'époque il
y avait des frontières très contrôlées
parmi l'Europe le douanier qui est
filtré les véhicules
il nous arrête il regarde
l'immatriculation il fait signe qu'on
pouvait passer
mon destin était au bout de ce doigt là
je n'oublierai jamais ce moment là
en France au bout d'un an je suis
convoqué à la préfecture de la Moselle à
Metz parmi nombreuses personnes je me
retrouve dans une très grande salle
pour apprendre
si j'avais droit de rester en France où
je devais quitter c'est un moment très
stressant
un monsieur qui sort d'un bureau avec
une liste dans la main il commence à
citer les noms
de nouveau je Fuster
là
comme si le toit de la préfecture
mettait tombé sur la tête
malgré mon très mauvais français je
décide de pousser la porte ou les
fonctionnaires ont été présents
je demande mais pourquoi pourquoi moi
rejeter
dans mon dossier
un document qui s'appelle la procuration
de mes parents ah bon c'est tout après
quelques appels en Turquie j'obtiens
cette procuration du coup je fus
autorisé rester en France
et légalement
manque de chance
mon cadre familial devient difficile
aujourd'hui on dirait dysfonctionnel
bref mon nouveau cadre en France fut la
rue
quelques temps après par hasard dans un
foyer qui s'appelle foyer horizon à
Forbach je rencontre une vieille dame
qui a eu un petit pied de moi qui
j'allais apprendre que c'était la
directrice du foyer horizon
que je pouvais héberger dans ce foyer
qui m'a permis de accéder à une
formation comme mineur de fond à
l'époque la mine produisait encore
donc cette formation à l'issue de cette
formation je devais m'insérer dans
professionnellement dans mon nouveau
cadre de vie et en tant que contremaître
je termine la formation
encore une fois manque de chance
malheureusement coup de grisou depuis
Simon 22 morts une centaine de blessés
l'information arrive à mes parents en
Turquie mes parents préféraient que je
prends le risque retourné au lieu de
mourir dans la mine
encore une fois il fallait changer cette
fois-ci cadre professionnel
donc
j'ai décidé de m'orienter vers le
secteur de bâtiment à l'époque tous les
Turcs travaillaient dans les façades
donc c'est ainsi que je me suis trouvé
dans le bâtiment comme vous voyez on
remplacement d'une personne j'ai
commencé dans une entreprise de façade
et je suis devenu façadier et ainsi je
chef d'équipe d'autres temps je me suis
marié et devenu papa
l'entreprise ferme le chômage me
rattrape
cette fois-ci
au lieu de changer mon cadre je décide
de créer mon cadre moi-même
parce que mon seul vrai métier c'était
Facilier
à mon meilleur ami
Haïdar qui est parmi nous ce soir
je suis propose de
lui former en tant que façadier et
monter notre affaire pour s'en sortir
parce qu'il avait une situation
similaire à moi
on a cherché à nous en dissuader
comme quoi il y aurait des charges à
payer des risques à prendre des impayés
à supporter que du négatif
mon ami Fayet renoncer mais je l'ai
convaincu de tenter notre aventure
je lui dis que dans ce tableau tout noir
je voyais plein d'étoiles
dans ce nouveau cadre bien sûr que ça va
pas été facile aucune banque ne voulait
nous ouvrir un compte encore moins les
fournisseurs
mais avec une envie et rencontre des
belles personnes et travail de qualité
on pouvait que réussir ce qui s'est
passé 33 ans après nous travaillons à ce
jour temps de pays avec une centaine de
salariés dont de plus fidèles qui sont
parmi nous aussi qui sont devenus
associés musées et airedales et une
jeune génération qui nous ont rejoint
qui se préparent pour prendre la relève
et nous réalisons des projets
prestigieux de la région avec une belle
perspective
mon ami il se prépare
prendre sa retraite bien méritée
et moi je me sens plutôt à ce jour
épanouie
accompli
pendant ce temps-là quand même j'ai eu
des moments émotionnels
comme
25 années après
dans la même salle de préfecture où j'ai
appris que j'étais rejeté j'ai eu
l'honneur de recevoir le grand prix
d'insertion de l'année 2015 de la mère
de président de conseil départemental
j'ai eu aussi
plaisir de retourner à ce feuilleton 20
ans après pour faire un don
et changer avec la nouvelle directrice
qui a eu l'arme aux yeux
j'étais aussi témoin avec mon épouse de
remise de diplôme de mon fils
de ma sœur
commerce internationale et ma fille en
tant que architecte intérieur c'était
des moments exceptionnels et émotionnel
mais
quand même à ce jour dans mon cadre de
vie il y a deux questions que je me pose
et qui me dérange
la première
ça concerne la communauté alibi dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure en quelques
mots
la situation des oliviers en Turquie à
empirer aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
encore de la famille chez des j'apprends
tous les jours les risques
à l'occasion d'une conférence publique
organise à Strasbourg ou
le président de la République turque
Abdul akul allait intervenir pour faire
un discours et j'étais invité en ma
qualité de porte-parole des individus
d'Europe je lui ai posé une simple
question
pourquoi Monsieur le Président pourquoi
les allées vis sont-ils aussi maltraités
en Turquie
il m'a dit évitez de poser ce genre de
questions en public
donc cette question reste toujours
d'actualité sans réponse et ça
s'amélange
la deuxième ça concerne mon métier
façadier ce beau métier
nous avons toujours eu problème de
recrutement de techniciens qualifiés
dans notre métier et je demandais
toujours pourquoi
pénurie de main d'oeuvre qualifiée dans
notre domaine pourquoi il y a pas de
formation pourquoi il y a pas d'école
je cherche la réponse personne ne sait
me répondre
à la fin prenons la période de covid en
plus j'ai décidé de créer notre propre
école
avec l'adhérence l'adhésion de
miclowbrateur nous avons décidé de créer
l'école bien sûr au début on s'est moqué
de nous
nous l'avons créé notre
première académie de façade de France et
depuis 3 ans nous formons des
techniciens qualifiés et nous sommes
fiers de l'avoir fait
mais certes c'est une solution locale et
privée c'est un problème général
pourtant le métier de façadier c'est un
jeu économique écologique et esthétique
de notre cadre de vie de tous les jours
de notre habitation
surtout avec isolation thermique par
l'extérieur pour réduire et nos factures
j'ai décidé de pousser tous les portes
toutes les portes jusqu'à Paris
j'étais reçu par Monsieur le Président
de la République François Hollande qui
m'a écouté attentivement qui m'a permis
de accéder à certaines mystères j'ai
rencontré aussi des ministres concernés
vous savez quoi
personne n'était au courant que ce
métier n'existait pas officiellement en
France
il y a pas de métier de façadier il y a
pas de code AB spécifique qui peut
permettre d'ouvrir à une école
contrairement l'Allemagne et les pays
Bénélux pourtant ce métier existe depuis
décennie
mais il n'existe pas officiellement et
personne s'est posé la question
j'étais invité par ministère de
l'Économie à Paris Bercy il y a trois
semaines j'ai partagé le problème avec
les solutions j'étais attentivement
écouté et je suis intégré dans un groupe
de travail pour traiter ce sujet et du 6
mois de juin j'espère que on va voir un
changement et je suis convaincu cette
fois ça va bouger vous allez voir
voyez
de changement de cadre ont changé mon
cadre il y a une question qui revient
c'est la question pourquoi
rappelez-vous dès l'enfance on nous
apprend à obéir ne pas poser des
questions ne pas déranger
je pense que dans mon cas
poser la question pourquoi ma conduit à
pousser des portes et changer de sortir
de cadre
peu à peu changer le cadre lui-même pour
finir
poser la question pourquoi peut vraiment
changer beaucoup de choses et nous
permettra de sortir de cadre merci
[Applaudissements]